natalie de celle reid has died the star
of movies like
baps and medea's big happy family was
53.
according to tmz the actor was diagnosed
with colon cancer earlier this year
and she was surrounded by family in her
final days
i'm his biggest fan he must have three
dozen trophies
i've never seen i'll make him keep that
crap in the garage natalie also starred
in the tv series eve
and the 1997 adaptation of cinderella
several of natalie's co-stars took to
social media to mourn her passing
how many c notes we talking here ten
thousand dollars
halle berry posted a tribute on
instagram writing
i'm in total shock completely
heartbroken
gonna need a minute hashtag rest in
peace
eve tweeted i can't believe it bow wow
starred alongside her in tyler perry's
medea's big happy family
he wrote on twitter sending my love and
condolences
out to natalie desell's family holly
robinson-pete said her mother was
natalie's manager at one point
she tweeted she will be so missed
sending out prayers to her children
and husband rest in peace sweet girl
you